bienvenue à grands reportages depuis des
mois maintenant la pandémie pose un défi
presque inhumain à tous les travailleurs
de la santé à tous les travailleurs de
l'ombre qui s'acharnent à sauver des
vies a cherché un médicament ou un
vaccin
un combat inédit qui est loin d'être
finie aussi pour la quête de réponses de
vérité et d'imputabilité et
l'information un service essentiel est
au coeur de cette lutte pour interroger
expliqué témoigner des enjeux auxquels
nous sommes tous confrontés très souvent
entre la détresse et l'espoir
l'équipe de rad a voulu témoigner de ses
efforts au quotidien d'oran d'heure de
tous les artisans qui sont derrière
comme devant la caméra quand les
entrevues que vous verrez ont été
détournés en juin dernier
on se doutait bien qu'il y aura une
deuxième vague cela dit vous verrez dans
ce docu réalité comment l'info a su
s'adapter pour continuer de vous servir
voici une incursion inédite dans les
coulisses de l'information bienvenue à
cette émission spéciale où on prendra le
temps de faire le point sur cette crise
en a été plongé dans la plus grande
crise économique sanitaire politique que
peut-être
mais mes enfants ne connaîtront genève -
c'est ce que j'ai couvert de plus dur
c'était pas juste avec défi
journalistique
c'est un défi
dumel global est incessant c'est
tellement de vagues qui suivent ces six
communes ont lancé un caillou que ça
arrête pas je trouvais sur toujours très
difficile de penser que ma mère vivait
cette situation là bonsoir mesdames
messieurs d'abord un mot pour vous dire
que comme beaucoup d'entre vous ma vie
bousculés ces jours-ci quand je fais le
téléjournal c'était mon travail il
fallait que je raconte le mieux possible
toute cette crise là je pleurais
beaucoup après en fait tu peux pas faire
d'erreur tu peux partir des des rumeurs
justement des forces nouvelles puis tu
veux vraiment pas faire ça moi c'est la
première fois dans la vie je fais des
insomnies quoi nous on aime sur les
journalistes
être dans la
la tempête alors on était vraiment à la
tempête au quotidien on le savait que la
pandémie présentait des conditions
idéales pour un accroissement du volume
la désinformation mais à ce point là
c'est une déferlante
une comédie de feu semble ça aurait
contracté le virus est difficilement
tenable
20 millions de personnes sont placées en
quarantaine notamment one
on avait comme le sentiment que ça
resterait en chine ça se passait en
chine et était raymond voyait le
confinement ce qui se passait à one ne
pensais jamais khaled gros comme ça
un verrouillage cette ampleur c'est du
jamais vu et lu tout comme si la
dimension quand de découvrir c'est à
dire à quel point ce que la chine dit
est vrai que c'était un peu extravagant
ce qui se passait et je crois qu'on
réalisait pas du tout que ça allait
venir ici on voulait pas l'imaginer en
fait que ça venait ici parce que c'est
humain on se dit c'est pour les autres
saillard désespoir ça viendra pas au
québec
mardi soir il ya un me contacter le
médecin dans un hôpital du centre-ville
de montréal qui m'a appelé il m'a dit
david et débutants dernier reportage
tepa sur la pandémie est dit assieds toi
je vais te parler pendant 15 minutes tu
vas comprendre que ça allait on m'a dit
j'ai vu un homme arrivé avec des
symptômes de strass
le tos accueilli pas de masque en
pensant qu'il avait une simple grippe
et le lendemain matin ce sont des gens
du jewish qui sont venus le chercher
équipés en home grenouille et il était
un tube et quand il est sorti douze
heures plus tard donc il dit prépare
pour être là dessus à temps plein et
puis faire attention parce que c'était
covin nineteen knb caractérise aux
pommes demi la toute première émission
spéciale le vendredi je me souviens hors
prix le plateau ici à et redis c'est la
combine un plan catastrophe nous
horaires et nos habitudes seront
chamboulées pendant quelques temps
toutes les écoles cge universités
garderies du québec sont fermés pour
deux semaines on a vu en quelques heures
que les émissions spéciales elle est se
succèdent et puis que saleh est un
rythme d'enfer pour plusieurs semaines
bonsoir la progression du coronavirus
continue de s'accélérer au pays
fermetures d'écoles annulation
d'événements partout sur la planète les
mesures pour combattre la pandémie
déboule faut être réaliste on est dans
une crise qui va durer des mots
les québécois sont très nombreuses
depuis hier aller à l'épicerie et non
juste être dos va travailler à la maison
jusqu'à nouvel ordre sa femme sophie
grégoire a ressenti des symptômes qui
s'apparentent aux coded 19 ce sont des
temps exceptionnel du jamais vu dans
l'histoire moderne
c'est la pire journée depuis 1940 à la
bourse de toronto qui borde la fermeture
de tous les lieux publics de
divertissement les bains les cinémas les
jim fait confie-t-il
je vous autres je vous en supplie
distance de 2 m m et demie 1 m une bulle
les explications du docteur horacio
arruda
j'ai jamais eu d'enfant ottawa de son
côté presse les canadiens à l'étranger
de revenir maintenant le québec
enregistrent premiers morts et vin
nouveau cadre coronavirus fermeture de
la plus longue frontière du monde celle
entre les etats-unis et le canada plus
du tiers de l'humanité 2 milliards 600
millions de personnes sont confinées
chez elles
les jeux olympiques sont reportées d'un
an et les morts se multiplient
faux
donc aujourd'hui j'ai pris la décision
de fermer toutes les entreprises et tous
les commerces sauf pour les services
essentiels les médias sont un service
essentiel
les médias sont considérés comme étant
un service essentiel était en plein
coeur du canada grc sur ça discute
informer accompagner la population s'est
connecté
aujourd'hui on est quoi on est combien
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui le 23 ans donc le premier
ministre hugo a annoncé que le québec
était en pause pour tous les autres
stands d'information qui travaillent ici
au quotidien ils ont les enfants la
maison
et doivent faire attention à eux puis en
même temps ils doivent continuer à
travailler dans un milieu où tout le
monde est assis rapprocher même si
depuis cinq-six jours on a vraiment
déplacé le maximum d'équipés on est allé
chercher deux places ici pour pouvoir
leur permettent de prendre plaisir
tandis que la rédaction numérique un
grand jour la passion on évolue à
franchement d'heure en heure de ce
studio est ce que je vais être capable
de produire mes missions d'information
rds que je vais être capable de
continuer à informer le public tout le
temps on ne savait pas tant que ça on
est guidé par ça mais on ne savait pas
sortir du cadre il réfléchir autrement
nos émissions qui voit qu est-ce qu on
préfère des croix derrière
honnêtement je peux pas croire qu'on
soit pas capable et eric woerth on a
besoin de la siens
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir bienvenue
à cette émission spéciale
covey 19 découverte en direct c'est
important a expliqué pour éviter la
situation l'italie tout ça c'est comme
ça on peut préparer l'émission je peux
vous dire qu'on respecte et pas vraiment
encore le maître ou le 2 mètres on
faisait attention elle demain tu existes
mm pô et on a appris on a écouté point
presse ensemble alors c'est comme ça que
j'ai appris que le grand animateur
chante c'est aller 70 ans et plus en
fait juste avant notre diffusion en
direct de l'émission le premier ministre
legault a dit aux personnes âgées en way
à la maison il m'a regardé et m'a dit
mais qu'est ce que je fais est ce que on
fait quand même les missions et j'ai dit
oui absolument il faut on a besoin de
toi et tu expliqueras pourquoi oui
effectivement à marier j'ai 70 ans il
faudrait pas conscients tombées malades
comme qu'on en convenant hawks et
services là alors la meilleure façon
d'empêcher ça c'est qu'on retourne à la
maison pour ne pas tomber malade et j'ai
trouvé que c'était très élégante sa part
de faire ça puis en même temps ce tas
d'informations
après l'émission je retourne chez moi
est dorénavant ça va être le télétravail
pour moi et en favorise de plus en plus
ici dans la grande tour le télétravail
jamais j'aurais pu penser qu'on aurait
pu mettre tant de personnes en
télétravail ne s'entend là il faut
qu'ils mettent au micro atx à huit morts
lui moi ça m'a obligé à me numérisés
complètement malfa bêtise et si je puis
dire sur le plan numérique parce qu'en
bon baby boomers et les choses que je
faisais assez bien et d'autres choses
que je sais pas bien du tout ou que je
ne savais pas faire
là j'ai été obligé comme happy tce dans
l'eau si je puis dire il a fallu que
j'apprenne à nager
[Musique]
du côté des véhicules vieux sont
détruits après chaque affectation les
personnes détruit les équipements sont
des poignets toute une scène qui en
blesse c'est à ce moment là qu'on a
formé ce qu'on appelait un genre de
ouargla où l'équivalent d'un world
élection m pour la coved jean d'aquarium
avec une affectation dédié justement
coordonner tous les journalistes qui se
sont retrouvés à travailler sur la
pandémie
ça faisait 97% les journalistes la salle
de nouvelles ont commencé à travailler
sur le même sujet alors ça y est la
métropole du québec a décrété l'état
d'urgence on ne peut pas évacuer la
possibilité d'un effets économiques
dévastateurs pour des millions de
personnes
on retrouve yves pour un petit coup
d'oeil sur la circulation oui c'est très
très facile vraiment un désert d1
c'est la course contre la montre partout
dans le monde pour tenter d'obtenir de
l'équipement médical à cause de la
pandémie coronavirus au québec l'accès à
huit régions vulnérables et désormais
contrôlés par des barrages policiers
une prestation canadienne d'urgence des
gens recevront 2000 $ du gouvernement
fédéral à tous les mois pour les quatre
prochains mois si vous ne respectez pas
les consignes vous risquez de mettre la
vie d'autres personnes en jeu c'est ce
qu'il dit depuis quelques jours monsieur
trudeau on reçoit tous les jours des
centaines et certaines journées des
milliers de questions à radio canada rdi
dans les différentes émissions le flot
de questions commentaires appel à l'aide
qu'on a reçue assez inouï inouïe
je reçois pas rendu puis début de
l'émission spéciale beaucoup de
courriels dès lors sa voie il ya la pcu
aps les gens au début c'était pas ça
comme si on avait fermé la lumière de
tout un pays
puis les gens cherchaient dans le noir
pas mal
bonjour ici michel sur orge et bienvenue
à nos auditeurs de tout le réseau
il fallait aussi dire le relayer aux
jeunes des directions de santé publique
qui disait tout ce que vous avez appris
à faire la fête les pu donner plus la
même personne adressé flux aux enfants
vous êtes très nombreux mesdames et
messieurs nous envoyer des questions et
avec raison concernant le coronavirus le
co 20 19
on a décidé régulièrement de faire le
point avec le dr karl weiss les
courriels que j'ai reçus là c'est à la
fin de la curd parce que il faut
imaginer d'abord il ya beaucoup de
solitude c'est pas tout le monde qui ont
trois enfants un mari une femme
il a des gens qui étaient seuls dans
leur appartement et que ce lien qu'ils
avaient
c'était la télévision des cameramans des
gens régit les réalisateurs des
journalistes sont sur le terrain pour
vous parce qu'on sera là du début à la
fin de toute cette histoire où tout
début les gens avaient besoin d'adhérer
à ce qu'on leur disait parce que c'est
tellement anormale ce qu'on vivait
collectivement les gens ont fait le
choix de dire je vais écouter ce que la
santé publique me disent que monsieur
legault me dit les journalistes passé
presque pour des traîtres l'audible
endémique ce pourquoi il pose une
question est ce que vous prenez une part
de responsabilité dans la situation
écoutez je pense que ce qui se passe
actuellement est le gouvernement a tout
misé en place poser des questions à un
ministre ou une ministre responsable de
je critique comme comme la pandémie
c'est notre devoir de journaliste on
sait que la personne interviewée des
mois post mais on n'est pas là pour
faire plaisir s'est produite en gratuit
d'antenne c'est pas des relations
publiques
c'est un service public pour faire des
derniers c'est le jeune femme se dit les
meilleurs discours il ya discours que
vous tenez un point de presse qu un
gouvernement que dieu la réalité terrain
par exemple les renforts là est-ce
qu'ils vont s'occuper des couches est ce
qu'ils vont faire manger les gens
est-ce qu'ils vont appeler les femmes et
sport les médecins qui vont changer des
couches et des bénéficiaires d'un sachet
celle d'ella écoutez madame de soul à la
fin de la journée comme disent les
anglais les gens font la différence puis
comprennent qu'on a un job à faire et
qui est d'assurer sur le point les
rennais les sachets celle des deux plus
jeunes
nadir autour de pâques même le premier
ministre disait l'espoir est là on va y
arriver les beaux jours sans vienne qui
après ça a été la période la plus dure
au contraire
les beaux jours sont pas arrivées
pleinement se sont accumulés plus
c'était plus drôle du tout là les arcs
en ciel puis la musique n'était plus là
dedans du tout on était dans l'horreur
des sachets saleté lartigue la gazette
legault qui fait une conférence de
presse samedi trente et une personnes
âgées sont décédées en moins d'un mois
aussi à celle des privés héron à dorval
dans l'ouest de montréal et l'autre dit
au plat
cette crise là elle devait locale spl
crise mondiale
c'est notre crise aux deux résidences
pour personnes âgées ont été mis sous
tutelle
aujourd'hui on est en train de rendre
compte que ce huis clos que sont devenus
un peu les résidences pour personnes
âgées et les ressources intermédiaires
semble cacher un problème assez
important les ch et celle des scellés
sont frappés de plein fouet 177 ont
maintenant au moins un cas confirmé de
coved 19 et derrière c'est maintenant il
ya eu des drames humains quand je
travaille je toujours à risque parce que
je suis pas protégés pourquoi je pour
protéger parce que ce qu'un qui disent
qu'ils manquent pas d'équipement mais
c'est pas vrai on actuellement tous les
équipements qu'on ne besoin cave un
écart entre les faux ou la tonalité à
québec
est ce que nous on attendait à montréal
dans le centre de montréal ont rejoint
beaucoup de messages par texto par
courriels de gens qui sont inquiets
qu'ils me disent écoutez on n'a pas
nécessairement assez de masques dans
toutes les circonstances je pense que le
travail qu'on a fait pour seulement
radio canada je parle des médias au sens
large c'est d'essayer de pousser pour
que l'information qui était connu dans
les établissements deviennent
public le plus rapidement possible pour
que les autorités se dépêchent a envoyé
d'équipement les mesures d aide au
personnel qui à un moment donné était
débordé banny qui consterné avec des
familles qui n'avaient plus de contact
avec les jeunes des cités c'est une
situation que je me remette dans le plus
m'inquiéter que tu es complètement folle
tu avais de la situation d'ailleurs
continue de se dégrader dans des sièges
celle de la région de laval wells et de
grade dans la plupart de ces achats
soldés de la région de montréal mais
c'est est-ce un moment donné un contact
à l'hôpital notre dame qui m'a appelé
qui me dit ce médecin qui sont en
quarantaine
le jeu phare qui c'est parce qu'ils ont
été en contact avec un corps qui s'est
révélé un positif et ils n'étaient pas
équipés fac c'est là qu'on comprenait
petit bout par petit bout qu'on commence
à comprendre que le réseau était port
elle n'avait pas les réflexes pour faire
face à ça et n'avait pas l'équipement
pour faire face à ça
[Musique]
il y à un lieu où la progression du
corona virus a de quoi inquiéter
beaucoup les foyers d'infection dans les
résidences pour aînés se multiplient et
le de semaine en semaine avec d'autres
collègues comme thomas gerber ont
commencé à pousser pour se rendre compte
qu'ils avaient des cas dans les sièges
celle des beaucoup beaucoup dans les
ressources pour personnes à angers aussi
il ya des registres dans les ch et celle
des avec les morts l'athlète donc tu as
le nom des résidents
la date de naissance leur date de décès
la cause du décès balle en l'occurrence
y avait comme une colonne que vide puis
à des sources à l'intérieur qui me
donnait le registre avec les dessins
évidemment et de données qu'il ya des
informations confidentielles la donne je
pouvais pas dire qu'il avait donnée puis
je diffusais pas le registre l'avait
fait mais ça me permettait de valider ok
si si il y en a cinquante cinq morts là
je le vois c'est écrit si je pouvais
dire à nos patrons j'allais le document
assez pas juste une infirmière qui
m'indique donc c'était une des
techniques pour être capable de prouver
qu'il y avait plus de morts que ce qu'on
disait les hôpitaux c'est selon pour m
façon j'ai l'impression que longueur
gentiletti gerbe et tout le monde est à
peine mal saisies sont ensuivies dès ce
jour qui sait ce qui peut juste sacré
coeur mais les autres et après on a
découvert qu surtout dans les vieux
hôpitaux qui était supposé d'être le
premier rempart c'est à dire sacré-coeur
et maisonneuve rosemont qui avaient des
éclosions importante
puis david gentilles et à montréal il ya
une éclosion dans les département
d'oncologie d'hémodialyse à l'hôpital
sacré-coeur et le ski est un peu
dramatique ce qui ça nous arrivait pas
de québec tu le sais que ça nous
arrivait des médecins ça nous arrivait
des infirmières qui nous appelaient pour
nous dire hey on un étage complet qui
est infectée ou d'un syndicat qui nous
disait on à 15 infirmiers avec sont
infectés long terme et voyons qu'est-ce
qui se passe
les médecins raconte une réalité de plus
en plus brutale dans les résidences
privées pour personnes âgées
c'est la catastrophe les médecins par
exemple c'est pas des gens qui avaient
l'habitude de parler beaucoup aux
journalistes avant la crise c'est pas
des gens quittent est plutôt réservé
qui parlait pas souvent à visage
découvert et là ils se sont lâchés
complètement on manque définitivement de
bras on manque de ressources humaines
pour les vins l'exercice jeunes
improvisent jusqu'à me and g de sucre
chaleur un déguisement coville friendly
lorsqu'il est arrivé après et compte
dont on a pris la mesure où simplement
d'années s'est il y avait des défections
il y avait des préposés terroriser des
infirmières terrorisés qui quittait on
savait pas à quel point c'était
contagieux on n'avait pas d'équipement
ils trouvaient des gens morts dans
l'argent ils nous appelaient et 10 et
j'ai vu quelqu'un qui était comme une
grille mort depuis des mois je reste pas
ici je parle tantôt au téléphone tu dis
il m'appelait pour me raconter ça les
gens m'appelaient pour me raconter je
suis rentré au ch et celle des ce matin
il y avait trois mois sur l'êta âge je
vais plus être là moi je pars dans le ch
et celle des leaders mais disons que je
trouve assez consternant je comprends
pas que ça fait une semaine qu'on dit
qu'il va y avoir des jeunes c'est
fermière des débiteurs mais ils sont où
ces gens là c'est eux
une urgence c'est vraiment un cri du
coeur
si tu sais pas
[Musique]
c'est une crise parfaite touche tous les
aspects de tous les gens donc tout seul
les aiguilleurs les réalisateurs les
journalistes les rédacteurs dans nos
vies comme citoyen mais on était de
toucher ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas
en fait on se retrouve par exemple moi
j'ai couvert des gays rouge et que vous
cherchez dans des zones de conflit mais
il ya tout on est toujours très perturbé
par ce qu'on voit on est toujours très
touché parce qu'on voit mais il ya quand
même une certaine distance d'une
certaine façon puisqu'on raconte
l'histoire d'autres personnes on raconte
l'histoire de victimes on essaie de
faire comprendre à nos téléspectateurs
ce que ces gens leur ressemblent vive
mais nous mêmes on vit pas
nécessairement la crise de la même façon
alors que là je trouvais qu est ce qu
avait de vraiment particulier c'était
que comme tous les citoyens du canada du
québec on visait cette crise de la même
façon au jour le jour de façon
personnelle et comme journaliste en même
temps c'est à dire pour essayer de
trouver les meilleures zones où pourrait
se trouver ce qu'il fallait dire aux
gens ce qu'il fallait raconter aux gens
du coeur idée alors de retour avec nos
aînés du québec et de la région d'ottawa
pour le point de presse du premier
ministre françois n'a pas été qu'à la
fin on s'est rarement question du moment
là le monde m'a vraiment maps et ses
grands papables ccc moindre george c il
n'y a pas là dedans tu as peur la trappe
et c'est tout le monde y passe d'être
épais et et nous on doit composer avec
cette peur là faux faux faux y faire une
place en même temps que penser à patrick
allemand non plus
alla sarr l exercice un peu plus période
d'émission
[Musique]
j'ai travaillé comme un fou je me suis
j'ai fini des articles à 1h à 2h du
matin puis je n'arrivais pas à suffire
aux besoins de sources de gens qui
disaient s'il vous plaît on a besoin de
vous il ya ça qui se passe je disais ah
mais c'est vraiment important ouais mais
il ya ça aussi ça c'est vraiment
important
j'étais comme déborder d'histoire
importante mais on en donne il fallait
que je me couche je veux dire fallait
que je dorme fallait que je vive et il
ya le bébé et tout ça mais je dirige est
dû il ya des gens qui j'ai pas pu
répondre il ya des histoires importante
qui peut-être n'ont pas que j'ai pas pu
faire qui n'ont pas permis d'aider et
peut-être gens qui sont mortes et je
sais pas à cause que j'ai pas pu faire
l'histoire j'en sais rien et je pourrai
jamais savoir mais de pas être capable
de suffire à toutes ces sollicitations
ça c'était comme parce que c'est des
appels à l'aide si c'est dur quand même
de d'ignorer les appels à l'aide
oui c'est vrai qu'une carrière un moment
donné moi qui a commencé à m'habiter
beaucoup beaucoup le sait pas comme une
inondation ou dans cette affaire le sait
il ya une portion sur laquelle on avait
le contrôle et on ne leur profite
mais
il ya quatre ans je faisais des
reportages sur la main d'oeuvre ses
intérêts c'est pas toujours les jeunes
on en a joué beaucoup on a autant de
produits radio quand on a vraiment fait
notre bout pour parler de main d'oeuvre
le 4 1 t'as pas très sexy fallait
vouloir le faire la pénurie de préposés
aux bénéficiaires et si c'était un sujet
qui n'était pas si facile que ressort à
rendre on se rend compte qu ont sonné le
tocsin un peu dans le vide blanc mais on
avait vachement raison le fait notre job
est à 4 heures puis on l'a fait pendant
la pandémie de mettre la pression sur le
réseau
ce réseau aussi on le sait les
travailleurs de la santé sont parmi les
premiers touchés par le cornet virus à
montréal ça donnait lieu à cette
histoire on va vous raconter tragique
une mère de famille préposés aux
bénéficiaires à dorval entre autres qui
a involontairement effecté ses cinq
enfants et son mari mort quelques
semaines plus tard un budget il est ce
drame leur rassembler tout ce qu'il ya
eu de pire dans cette épidémie l'eau une
préposée a effecté
parce qu'elle avait manqué d'équipement
parce qu'on augmente les personnels qui
ramène soeur à la maison qui infecte son
mari qui meurent de ce nom nous ratés
collectifs dans ce pandémie l'oms
ça fait cinq orphelins ça c'est ce qui
se passe je vais simplement coupé g inné
culpabilité qui me ronge lesquelles je
suis tellement prisés ça a été une
aventure humaine pour moi le extrêmement
difficile
parce qu'à la dame voulait me rencontrer
avant de donner l'entrevue et c'est donc
j'ai été chez elle le soir avant
j'écoutais l'entrevue évidemment elle
est totalement bouleversée et puis le
lendemain pendant l'entrevue un moment
donné à 10 heures
e
qu'est ce que je vais faire g5 enfin mon
mari n'est plus là c'est moi qui l'a
affecté la culpabilité que je ressens un
terrible
il ya des orphelins et en plus chez un
5/6 ans faire comment je vais faire je
ne sais pas comment je vais m'en tirer
et puis l'heure m raconte que
elle me raconte que son enfer de deux
heures ils se promènent encore dans la
maison et comprend pas que son père est
mort
la copine et puis cherche dans le coeur
de rome puis dit papa tu es ou papa t'es
où
la jolie chapelle taches claires et a
tiré jeudi un profond s'est occupé à
l'entrevue que c'est toi qui te mets là
tu peux plus être détachés dans sa phase
terminale d'un an et demi que je
l'écoutais j'étais renversé j'ai trouvé
ça dur parce que je me suis dit que
c'est pas vrai que ça aurait pu être
autrement
[Musique]
m
ce monsieur qui qui avait qui avait eu
droit d'aller voir sa mère parce qu'elle
allait mourir c'était que la seule
raison qu'on pouvait aller voir son
propre sang séché celle décidé s'il
allait mourir
mais le fait que son fils soit là ll est
allé mieux fait finalement elle était
plus mourante
puis parce qu'elle était plus mourante
il n'avait plus le droit d'aller au chs
end avec moi j'ai trouvé que c'était
hallucinant sa révéler un peu le fait
qu'il y avait quelque chose qui
fonctionnait pas dans le système s'est
de fait qu'on avait banni les proches
aidants des établissements ça donnait un
regard sur ce qui sur une dame qui a la
queue vide qui est dans un sèche et
celle d envoyer toute sa fragilité
et puis il y en a pas beaucoup d images
qui venait de l'intérieur des ch et
celle d il en a pas eu beaucoup d'axés
attendait beaucoup de témoignages mais
on n'a pas vu beaucoup à quoi ils
ressemblent ces gens là qui ont à la
crevette l'envoyer
[Musique]
les syndicats
que tu ne t'attendais toutes ses
chansons
bonsoir mesdames messieurs contente de
vous retrouver un peu partout on voit
des signes encourageants mais quand même
lakovic 19 continue de progresser
c'est particulier parce que je vivais la
crise comme journaliste je la racontait
je raconterai l'histoire des autres et
tout à coup moi ma propre mère qui à 91
ans a fait un avc s'est retrouvé à
l'hôpital avec une perte d'autonomie
massive donc très grave accident et là
je vis la crise comme tant de familles
québécoises léo vécu c'est à dire que là
mais je pouvais pas voir ma mère donc
l'inquiétude qu'on peut avoir dans une
situation comme celle là quand on sait
que la personne l'une des personnes les
plus chers qu'on peut avoir
se retrouve dans une situation où elle a
besoin de nous et nous on est impuissant
à l'autre bout on peut rien faire et
elle se retrouve dans un hôpital où on
la croyait en sécurité mais là aussi
très rapidement un neurologue m'explique
madame si j'étais à votre place je
ramènerai mammaires chez moi mais je ne
réalise pas à ce moment là que ce
qu'essaie de me dire le médecin c'est
que si vous voulez protéger votre maire
de lac au vide il faut vouloir que vous
la ramenez chez vous parce qu'à
l'hôpital
elle est plus en sécurité alors ce que
je savais pas ce qu'il y avait une
éclosion à l'hôpital et que c'était en
train de se propager à une vitesse assez
phénoménal mais moi je n'ai pas compris
comme ça parce que on est encore au
début
de toute cette épidémie de cette
pandémie
ici donc je comprends pas ça alors
j'essaie d'organiser ça mais c'est pas
simple on est en période il manque de
personnel partout très difficile
d'essayer d'avoir des gens qui
pourraient venir prendre soin d'elle à
la maison et le temps que j'essaie
d'organiser ça mais ma mère attraper la
coved 19 elle à 91 ans elle vient de
faire un avc massif on réalise de plus
en plus à quel point d'isolement et
l'interdiction des visites ont aussi des
conséquences désastreuses
c'est vraiment pour moi très difficile
de vivre ça au niveau personnel et en
même temps j'ai une responsabilité au
téléjournal de raconter cette histoire
avec un certain détachement donc il ya
des moments où il fallait que je quitte
parce que j'ai essayé de parler au
médecin j'essaie par le zafira fallait
que je sois libre plus disponible en
fait donc j'ai dû me retirer puis à un
moment donné j'ai fait le choix de dire
aux gens ce qui se passait bonsoir
mesdames messieurs d'abord un mot pour
vous dire que comme beaucoup d'entre
vous ma vie
bousculés ces jours ci parce que ma mère
est dans un état grave à l'hôpital et
c'est ce qui explique mes absences
ponctuelles du téléjournal
j'ai aussi une pensée pour tous ceux qui
ont en ce moment des proches qui sont
hospitalisés ou qui sont dans des ch et
celle des parce que c'est insoutenable
l'angoissent qu'on peut vivre voilà mais
ce soir quand même moi je vais toujours
me poser cette question là en fait si ma
mère s'était pas retrouvée en isolement
si on avait pu garder un contact plus
plus plus près avec elle si on avait pu
être avec elle est-ce que les dommages
auraient été aussi important est ce que
on n'aurait pas pu l'aider je ne saurai
jamais en fait mais pour nous la vie
d'avant elle reviendra jamais donc tout
est différent en fait donc moi c'est ça
que je les retenir de cette crise
où
[Musique]
il ya un an avant
qui est un après
[Musique]
en même temps ça me donne une
sensibilité différente parce que souvent
on va couvrir les crises on va couvrir
un tremblement de terre en haïti par
exemple et ensuite on s'en va et on
al'impression on revient cinq ans après
et on dit le pays va mieux etc
mais les gens qui ont vécu cette crise
qui ont perdu tout ce qu'ils avaient qui
ont perdu des proches qui ont perdu
leurs familles qui ont perdu leur emploi
mais tous ne redevient pas comme avant
quand je pense que aussi là dedans une
leçon pour moi comme d'humilité comme
journaliste le 6
[Musique]
salue ici l'ex idole en serre et
bienvenue dans l'univers des décrypteurs
pour cet autre émission entièrement
consacrée à la désinformation des
premiers éléments d information c'était
vraiment le sur les remèdes
mais là quand confinement est arrivé les
théories du complot les théories
conspirationnistes sont arrivés par
vagues successives
le phénomène des monsieur madame dans
son salon aux qui ce film
et puis qui met ça sur youtube a
commencé à arriver et puis avec des
discours qu'ils y ait de personnes en
apparence convaincu mais qu'ils disent
absolument n'importe quoi balas les gens
ont commencé à embarquer et comme jamais
la population en général a été exposé à
des théories conspirationnistes et c'est
la grande différence avec la commune du
neuf avec la pandémie
ça existait auparavant mais ça reste est
somme toute dans des cercles assez
restreint on voit des youtuber
conspirationnistes qui ont 2000 ou 3000
vu sur une vidéo d'habitude là ils font
des vidéos sur mac avec 19 millions 500
mille cinq cent mille à un million les
conspirations ça joue beaucoup sur
l'apport isolement social sur le
sentiment d'impuissance face à une
situation bien on est tous là dedans
donc et puis nous concrètement ce que ça
génériques comme d'un travail de très
différent c'est le volume soutenu de
courriels sur une base quotidienne
je parle ici de centaines de courriels
des gens qui commencent à se poser des
questions est ce que ceci est vrai ce
que ceci est faux ce que ceci est vrai
et on voit dans ces courriels fait les
gens sont submergés d'informations que
leurs proches leurs envois et parfois
ils nous disent un membre de ma famille
un ami aussi recul a fait circuler ça je
sais pas quoi en penser ce que c'est
vrai dans la famille journalistique on
est et on a généré un type de contenu
qui très particulier
on s'est attaqué à un élément de la
pandémie auquel
les autres se sont - tarder et puis il
ya eu un backlash une réaction très
viscéral de ces personnes là parce
qu'une personne conspirationnistes qu'on
s'en prend cette théorie la laquelle
elle consacre beaucoup de temps l'on
s'en prend une extension d'elle même on
s'en prend ses parents s'en prend à eux
finalement d'où la virulence de la
réaction au piquage de la virulence
c'est pô juste pas d'accord avec vous
monsieur de lanceurs monsieur monsieur
et madame wathiq c'est vraiment on y va
à fond trail et puis ça a donné lieu à
des menaces des menaces très sérieuses
[Musique]
si vous continuez ben c'est une balle
dans la tête qui vous atteint la
pendaison et tout le reste et a fallu
gérer pas dans le détail
mais il a fallu que la police s'implique
dans certains cas parce que on peut pas
badiner avec ça la frontière est très
fuyante entre la boutade les fêtes toge
et la menace réelle qui peut mener à des
gestes concrets
[Musique]
matières premières la c'est tellement
pas gai c'est tellement tier 1 s'élèvent
comme on lit souvent la hausse
on est en albite de la dystopie halle
c'est ça notre note big quotidien c'est
ce cri 1984 tous les jours et puis une
chance qu'on s'est tenue jeff bouchra et
moi puis on s'écrivait constamment
explorer au dessus quand tu lis ce
message là est-ce que ça va aller
puis des appels et le soir on le
constate et et les autorités sanitaires
le dise la désinformation et les
théories du complot nuisent à la santé
publique mais ce poteau ans à cause
aussi du tort et de la détresse chez les
proches de personnes qui croient dur
comme fer à ce genre de théorie et ça va
parfois loin très très loin là où
vraiment moi ça m'a inquiété touché
énormément lancé c'est quand il ya des
messages qui nous sont parvenus de
femmes particulièrement qui partagent
leur vie avec un conjoint un tube ou un
mari conspirationnistes et qui au
quotidien se sont bien calés mg ou
contester un peu les théorie véhiculée
par leur conjoint et puis en retour ont
reçu beaucoup de violence et qui se sont
bien nous écrire plus jeunes en parlent
depuis les violents qu'est ce que je
fais à saissac arrive il ya des liens
d'amitié se sont effrités dans cette
pandémie l'un et des liens familiaux que
se sont effrités il ya des gens qui se
sont mis à dire cette personne là je
suppose qu'ils arrivent sur facebook qui
polluent et ce sera plus mon ami
facebook piano on a eu beaucoup de
secourir dans ce sens là mais bien
évidemment face à ces femmes vulnérables
on avait un certain nombre de conseils à
leur fournir mon propre on pouvait pas
leur venir en aide
comment comme on l'aurait voulu une
femme qui nous a aussi écrit et avec qui
on va parler l'instant même tout en
protégeant son identité pour ne pas
heurter la personne de son entourage
dont elle veut nous parler
bonjour madame je pense pas qu'on a la
prétention de demi de complètement faire
basculer les choses pour les
conspirationnistes pleurer deux c'est
plus les personnes qui sont pas
normalement dans cette dimension là des
choses qu'on essaie de protéger nos tous
ceux qui lisent pas les gens qui croient
à cela parce que comme jeff le 10 de son
instinct psychologique qui existe depuis
toujours et puis lui mais a tendance à
croire que les événements qui sont très
gros qui sont très dramatiques ont une
cause qui est proportionnelle aux
résultats donc là on a une pandémie qui
a tué des centaines des milliers de gens
cessons de penser que ce sont des
phénomènes marginaux la désinformation
que c'est ce que c'est le le produit
d'une bande 2 3 et lumineux non il faut
pas non plus diaboliser ces personnes
non c'est pas ça du tout l'idée pour
comprendre le phénomène
il faut comprendre qu'est ce qui pousse
ces gens-là disséminer des informations
qui sont trompeuses ou dans le pire des
cas fausse faut en être conscient qu'il
faut cesser de penser que c'est marginal
c'est le message que je voudrais martelé
pierre conséquences
je pense qu'il va falloir mandat n'y
consacrent un peu plus je suis parfois
de radio quand je parle en général de
ressources à cette lutte à la
désinformation
si on veut pas que ça pollue au delà
d'un certain seuil critique
l'espace médiatique l' architecture main
ou d'un des réseaux sociaux est basé sur
des cliques la visibilité le plus
possible dans un contexte de crise où il
ya beaucoup de désinformation c'est pas
bon ça
ce qui s'est produit là ça s'est produit
parce que le système est ainsi fait
celui des réseaux sociaux qui notre
système d'information les gens
s'informent de plus en plus sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est celle est de plus
en plus le point qu'on le veuille ou non
pour la télé les autres médias les
autres plateformes
c'est là dessus que des gens s'informent
de plus en plus c'est le moment mesdames
et messieurs de se dire au revoir mon
confinement à moi commence ce soir je
vais emporter plusieurs images fortes
cette crise les rues vides de ma ville
un faux calme qui cachait de la
souffrance je vais repenser souvent aux
gens qui font ce métier essentiel qu'on
ne voyait plus les préposés les
infirmières et producteurs maraîchers
je vais revoir souvent ce corridor d'un
siège celle des que j'imaginais ou des
personnes âgées sont décédées
seul j'entendais les cris de désespoir
c'est le drame de cette crise de
l'oublions jamais ce sentiment alors de
faire quelque chose d'important de faire
son devoir comme service public avec 1
to pas la remise pour essayer de trouver
un ton vrai qu'en ce sentiment était
partagé quelque chose de malgré tout
magique qui est arrivé ici pendant trois
mois ce fut un grand privilège de
traverser cette tempête avec vous à bien
e
parce qu'eux aussi avaient une grande
fierté de faire partie de sal je suis
celui qui n'est pas devant la caméra
mais tous les autres derrière
je veux ajouter quelque chose à des gens
qui sont pas interviewer le pour cela
faire long mais les recherchistes qui
sont essentielles dans une émission
comme la non tu trouves les gens qui
piquent qui font la présente revue les
recherchistes qui ont fait ça de la
maison souvent avec avec lena fans deux
ans il est maman maman ils ont été
extraites au temps qu'ils sont figés une
équipe qui est relativement jeune de
jacky qui il ya déjà la dalle la jeune
mais quand ça commence ce la maison lors
qu'ils ont livré la marchandise
c'est ce que bloc qui se font pas
interviewer pour ce show là non elles
ont été extraordinaires pis moi je gère
la dette de gratitude que je veux je
peux pas la dire tarde à guérir
je n'ai jamais connu un esprit d'équipé
comme ça de ma vie j'en ai fait des
affaires of le pid et jamais où les gens
étaient fiers de rentrer en régie ou les
gens étaient fiers
à la sortie de l'émission parce que
justement on avait fait des choses on
est allé au bout de nous retrouver avec
un notre correspondante à nîmes 0 à nice
une tragédie le qui se déroule t mais je
suis je suis content d'avoir été
journaliste pour voir aussi pour poids
poser des questions quand je pouvais
pour voir l'impact est d'être le relais
entre ce qu'ils vivent et ce qu'ils sont
pas bons on pouvait le savoir n'est pas
comme qui vive pour cette réalité un
petit et d'avoir été journaliste dans
des moments aussi forts que cette crise
là c'est exigeant mais revint à ce
privilège
le rayon de soleil de la pandémie c'est
personnel du réseau
malgré les terres du réseau il ya
beaucoup de monde que booker se trouve
ça formidable
je me suis dit pourrez vous rentrer là
dedans il y en a qui sont partis mais la
très vaste majorité sont rentrer là
dedans avec l'équipement tout croche pas
de connaissance sur le le virus
chapeau des pompiers des policiers qui
encourage les travailleurs et les
résidents du csld sainte-dorothée à
laval qui en ont bien besoin
ces crises beaucoup beaucoup appris sur
toutes les situations de ces personnes
âgées dont on parle souvent mais convois
peuvent en fait on voit peu on le
on le sait probablement parce que on
sait qu'il ya de la maltraitance on sait
qu'il ya eu des crises on sait que des
gens qui ont été ébouillanté dans le
bain on sait ce genre de chose quand une
crise qui se passe mais dans le
quotidien de leur vie je pense que c'est
des gens qu'on voit pas assez dont on se
préoccupe pas c'est quoi au québec on a
le plus haut pourcentage au canada de
gens qui vivent dans des résidences
pourquoi au québec on a
le plus haut pourcentage de personnes
âgées qui vivent seules pourquoi au
québec on a d'aussi mauvais un service
soins à domicile tout ça ce sont des
questions le qu'on est obligé de se
poser de parts dans cette pandémie lyon
pourquoi notre réseau réponse tant que
sur les hôpitaux pour qu'on donne pas
plus de soins à domicile
ce qui amène peut-être les gens vers des
résidences pour personnes âgées des chs
ld alors qu'ils auraient pu être chez
eux en sécurité si cette crise peut
changer quelque chose
ce sera c'est ça qu'il faut changer un
peu leur donner plus leur place de la
visibilité en fait dans notre société
qu'on les voit qu'elles fassent partie
de notre société un peu plus peut-être
qu'on s'en soucierait un peu plus sur
quoi je sais pas c'est dur quand même de
réaliser ça pour quelqu'un qui qui se
pensait très à l'écouté des problèmes
sociaux qu'on peut avoir dans notre
société et de réaliser qu'en fait on en
sait si peu
[Musique]
c'est un constat terrible en fait des
chèques je trouve mais c'est ça si au
moins cette crise peut changer cette
situation là bas ce sera ce sera déjà ça
faut pas oublier en fait
[Musique]